[Music]  i can feel you pulling things around in  there  it's a brand new organ  never before seen  [Music]  we've all felt that the body was empty  empty of meaning  and we've wanted to confirm that  so that we could feel it with meaning  [Music]  the world is a much more dangerous place  now that pain has all but disappeared  [Music]  surgery is sex isn't  it is it  you know it is  search the new sex  [Music]  i don't like what's happening with the  body  in particular what's happening with my  body  [Music]  which is why i keep cutting it up  what do you think they'd find inside  outer space  [Music]  sorry  let us not be afraid to map the chaos  inside  [Music]  let us create a map  that will guide us  into the heart of darkness  [Music]  do  [Music]  you